can we tell ray that put down the golf
club and come over here and talk my
array is the pole would you rather shoot
like Ray Allen or dunk like Vince Carter
62 percent would rather shoot like Ray
Allen okay alright I'm curious if Ray
had now gray used to be able to dunk
like he would dunk in traffic so I don't
know he can still dunk
alright so I all right I don't want to
offend you here ray sit down we're live
here come on you can take inventory
after all right
would you rather be able to shoot like
you shoot or dunk like Vince Carter
ducks I would rather be able to shoot
like ash you okay I did dunk yeah for a
good part of my career not like Vince
well I mean I had I had my moments when
I was up there and it seemed like it was
fun but there's a there's a there was a
point where it turned in and I think in
the last 1012 years where dunking was
just okay and then I started really
aspiring to be great shooters because
that was more demoralizing you know you
don't want to be on a meme nowadays
getting dunked on but being able to
shoot is much more powerful how many
times we ever dunked on like in a bad
way yes but I don't remember him you
don't it's like your body just pushed it
out of out of memory it's in there and
if somebody brought it up or if you
probably pull it in some archives you
could find Hollywood you look up
Ray Allen getting dunked on all over
them yeah just in case it and we refresh
your memory how you doing I'm doing
great you look good thank you so do you
could you play right now yeah you could
any interest No you paused a little bit
though well because I could doesn't mean
you have to but at the same time it's
like when you when you get to the other
side of it and you manage to escape
anything major issue wise yeah it's a
huge win but what if LeBron called you
well I think at this point in the game
and there's so many other things that
come into play because there's an older
player you can't just come and show up
you know you have to put a lot of work
in
and then you got a really play you know
the sitting down and getting back up and
sitting down is what does you to most
damage yeah but you could be a
specialist three-point specialist come
in give me 15 minutes at work no I mean
I've never wanted to be a specialist
I've always wanted to be a player and
you figure out what the game presents
you and if it's threes that you shoot
you shoot them but it's--but range is so
many different things that happen out
there
so if LeBron calls then you would just
say thank you not interested yeah I mean
you got to throw the kids to think at me
at least give me a think about it but
okay wait okay what what if he throws
the same country what if he throws to
sink center then we think about it
really
yeah then we think about it because two
sinks is to think so if I get eight
million for you one year mmm I mean
that's just good money but 10 million
we're starting to think okay so cuz the
Lakers are listening right now Jeanie
buss is listening right now yeah well
this they could use some three-point
shooters right they can use a lot I
think how do you think they're going to
do it being arrested interesting just
looking at you know their roster and I
don't I'm curious to see how they built
their roster did they build it to
contend with Golden State or did they
build it to make the playoffs did they
build it to to compete are they building
it for the future so it's an interesting
mix though because is Rondo the kind of
guy who will help
Lonzo ball get better that would be one
of the questions I'd have also you've
got these older guys and I'm gonna have
a really young locker room and an old
locker room are those veterans going to
include the younger players where the
younger players seek out the older
players and say help me get better
that's sort of the dynamic that I'm
curious about with the Lakers yeah and a
lot is gonna contend on those older
players and how they ingratiate
themselves
to this new mix because even LeBron has
to reinvent himself what kind of player
do you think he'll be it's difficult to
say because you know how he's been for
us and what we've seen over years past
when I played with him he had a lot
around him they could do different
things so he didn't always have to carry
the weight Cleveland is a little
different he needed more shooters around
him so he doesn't have that many
shooters around him so how are they
gonna fit in and you know Stephenson and
Ronda both need the ball in their hands
so is he gonna give up more that
responsibility and is he gonna become
somewhat of a spot-up shooter at the
same time or those guys then becomes
follow-up shooters gonna be interesting
to watch would you ever consider him the
best player of all time like what what
could does LeBron have to do something
or can he do something where you would
go now I would look at him as the best
player no I think he he certainly you
know just off the cuff he's certainly
top five of all times but playing
against him in MJ I think it for me it's
MJ all day long only because how I play
ting is him and you know the MJ just had
everything you know from mid-range to
three-point post up game and he could
score and dominate in each position
LeBron is dominant LeBron could do so
many things on the floor and do you
think you LeBrons are better all-around
player than Jordan yeah it's hard that's
hard to say because you know LeBron is
probably one of the best passers and you
know that the league is seen MJ is
probably that's probably the weakest
part of his game you know he didn't he
didn't pass a lot but at the same time
you know MJ didn't have any other
weaknesses in his game and defensively
he would he was a two-way player
defensively he was incredible and just
as dominant well I still look at LeBron
a better rebounder better passer Mike
was not shooting a three back then he
would have developed into a steal cos
shoot it yeah but LeBron has turned into
at least a dangerous 3-point shooter
like you have to
you have to account for him when he
takes those shots but the personality
though is I think that the biggest
different cuz Mike wanted to kill you
mm-hmm was he mean to you no he wasn't
he actually killed me slowly and yeah he
would comment to the coach he's actually
doing a great job out here and meanwhile
he's born at 45
wait he's talking to your coaches yeah I
remember uh Chris Ford he yelled at me
Chris Ford's yelling the whole time like
rookie didn't forget in front of him and
I'm fronting him on the post and MJ just
kind of slowly kind of glides across the
floor and he gets the ball and shakes
and scores and I did everything the
gameplan said and then there's a
breaking action we're sitting there and
you know Chris Ford is just down there
just hammering me and MJ's like he got
45 on the books yeah
did you think that Mike didn't want you
taken out because he had 45 in the books
like he wanted you to guard no I
honestly believe that he he didn't think
that anybody could stop him he can score
whenever he wanted to score where
everyone the score so it didn't matter
what I did out on the floor he was gonna
get his touches he's gonna get his
points more unstoppable though when they
get that mindset Michael or Kobe
certainly Michael really yeah because I
mean Kobe put up 81
yeah we're that was a bad two Ronald
defense at the time still 81 yeah yeah I
mean it's a marvelous 60 in his last
game he played yeah it was a marvelous
feat it's hard to really compare the
generations you know if you look at what
MJ did during his error like I played in
between both those errors and the rules
are totally different like you can't
touch a guy now you know you a guy will
go to the free-throw line 2025 times a
game just off of ticky tack stuff but it
used to in phil jackson said this when
he was promoting his book years ago if
mike played today he would average 45 in
his prime easy
you believe that mm-hmm yeah and that's
why it's you know so much is made about
the errors we just it's just not a
comparison to compare what we do now
what's going on now to what's happened
in the 80s to the 90s well they would
beat up James Harden now oh yeah
like they'd he'd go to the he'd go to
the floor a few times yeah if he flopped
once or twice they would make sure they
gave him a reason to flop yeah fall down
it wouldn't be them guessing you know
did somebody hit him right now when we
see a foul we're always guessing well
did he get touched what happened you
know
his hand went this way so it's always
like we're trying to decipher what
happened to play but back in the 80s and
early 90s it was like he just kind of
took his elbow and went right across his
head and it was a real foul yeah they
didn't call flagrant back then ya know
they would just say that's a foul it's a
hard foul yeah and when I got fouls yeah
when I got I remember going to the hole
as a young fella and you got knocked
down literally you got knocked down and
you you you wanted to go make a laugh
and you hit the ground if the ball went
in the air and they'll knock you down
and it's not a foul because the ball is
gone already nowadays it's excessive
they might throw you out of the game do
you ever want to fight somebody oh yeah
who I don't think there's anybody in
particular I think at times where your
emotions kind of get the best of you but
you're supposed to be trained not to
want to fight anybody you're supposed to
be it's like how do you go through
practice go through shooter rounds and
and just all this preparation like we're
supposed to be trained at these moments
in these situations but did you get a
cheap shot that you just said like I
want to I want to punch somebody well I
got into a fight one that I remember
against Keyon Dooling
he played with the magic and I was in
Seattle and it was a lot of chiefs not
throwing in that game and we went at it
you know we we threw punches and I got
suspended I think three games four would
you've done it differently or did you
feel like you know sometimes you have to
stand up for yourself yeah I would have
done anything differently it's it's I I
believe when things happen around around
the league around sports any sport if
you see somebody get punked or somehow
and you know somebody just tries you you
don't stand up for yourself you're gonna
have they're gonna do it again yeah
you're gonna have a tough time for rest
of that year all right we're gonna come
back raised during the commercial break
if we blindfold you from the free-throw
line
do you think you could shoot better than
we can on this whoo yeah not on this
hope no okay
you know the ceiling is yeah it's gonna
that's my home court advantage yeah it
in a normal on a normal hoop I
definitely could beat you you could beat
me blindfolded yeah because I know I got
to rely on getting the ball in the air
more you know blindfolded because I got
a hope that just sits up there softly
but here I don't have that that ability
is that if you shot a hundred
free-throws blindfolded on on your hoop
at home how many make probably 55 or 60
oh you're gonna need to do better than
that to beat me yeah well if I was hoop
at home is one thing in a gym is
different you're out in the open air
there's yeah I'm ready I don't know
parameters climate I'm ready my my eyes
will be open right I'm like a dolphin my
god yeah
sonar is out into the area I know like a
honing in on the hoop I know where it is
okay uh well well blindfold you and see
how many you could make though I gotta
even it out somehow so I got a you know
I was gonna say left-handed you wouldn't
beat me left-handed with I silver no you
would out of ten yeah yeah that's
possible oh it's possible but it's not
gonna happen well I'll bet my life on it
no no no I will I'll bet my all and my
life if you beat me no I don't you won't
take that bet I can even bet $100,000 on
you want that cuz I won't take your
money I just want you the studio is nice
I don't want to have any stock in and I
just want to come here visit okay fair
enough
all right we'll play nice here but we'll
shoot free-throws here with rate coming
up we'll take a break we're back after
this in the Dan Patrick show
brave do everybody's like us yes I mean
we've made it Angry founders yeah you
know the only one thing a lot of thing
we always say about shoes I mean you
shoot the ball you notice if your own
based on your misses sometimes so you
see some guys shooting the ball hits and
it just kind of he ends up way and crazy
place in the head well you can tell the
good ones when the ball hit to the
bounces somewhere and that's what good
rebound to break shooters putting on a
shooting display during the live look in
if you were watching as Ray Allen is
still with this two-time NBA champ 10
time all-star now hall-of-famer you want
to title with the Celtics and the heat
which title meant more to you probably
the the Celtics championship because I
hadn't won anything up to that point and
when you come from
you know Seattle where we had struggled
we had one playoff berth and to go from
you know the Celtics were worse to first
you know it was almost like unimaginable
so that probably you know when it's the
first time when you get there it's like
an amazing feeling you during your
speech gave a shout out to the Celtics
players winning a championship they're
still we've talked about this it's just
such a weird relationship or lack
thereof that continues why why is it
that there's it feels like there's
something that's always going to be
there unless it's the media that that
keeps it there because it feels like
you've tried to move on with it
or try to mend fences here yeah I've you
know even when I left it was you just
know that this is what you have to do
for your career and there's no like harm
you know you're not creating any
ill-will as I leave it's just all about
trying to figure out how to improve your
career I on what we did in the the the
five years we we spend together could
you have left different
left the Celtics differently and
therefore we wouldn't have well that
that to me is is really on the the IDB
holder I think the people who are who
feel some kind of way about me having
left obviously I was very loved in the
city and you know I still feel the same
way about the city because of what we've
done what we did so I've heard from
people that said oh we just hated you
went to Miami you know the fact that you
we hate LeBron you went to LeBron you
you couldn't went to Phoenix and it
would have been all good so it's yeah
it's a bunch of ideas where they they
were upset because of where I ultimately
ended up going and then the fact that I
won was even more of a wedge they drove
and and in people's mind so it's there's
nothing I can do about it you know
because I every sports personality every
player your job is to go and figure out
how to win and you know every person in
any walk of life at any job like you go
to figure out where you can best put
yourself in the situation you you could
be successful make the most money and
hopefully win if it's a sport
environment but you've also talked about
this that you had family telling you it
feels like you're being shunned that
you're not getting the ball yeah you
become an awful pic and Rondo is not
gonna throw you the ball right they're
telling you this and then did you come
to the realization of I'm being frozen
out here yeah and I wouldn't talk to to
talk about it and he acknowledged it and
I was surprised by that because I was
like well you acknowledge it and you
haven't done anything about yeah
so whatever happened to break down in
the relationship
it's unfortunate and that's why you say
well look it's with all these things you
know you you put throw it in a pot and
you stir it around it just means that
ultimately it's time for me to move on
as much as it bothered me because it was
you know playing the Boston was probably
the the most incredible experience
there's those fans yeah those fans you
know they're like no other so it's
unfortunate but you you got it's almost
like you're your
and you you got get your walking papers
and this time to go so there's nothing
more you know then your happiness that's
more important when you're in a
situation when you're working a job and
so it was ultimately time that the
writing was on the wall do you think
that katie has gotten fair criticism for
leaving oklahoma city to go you know
it's basically what you did yeah and I
heard the comparisons being made a lot
yeah I will say that when when I was a
free agent I knew that the time for me
was over and I had to decide that I was
not you know me the option to me signing
back with with Boston was was no longer
on the table and so ultimately I had to
decide where it was that I was gonna go
I had three teams left on the table that
was Miami Memphis and Minnesota so you
tell me yeah yeah you tell me you know
what where you also be able to end well
they all begin with em but yeah there's
one that stands out there's one of the
stands out weather and then there's
LeBron and D Wade yeah I mean it was
it's it's a no-brainer you know when you
know you got to put yourself in the
situation to win I think in KD situation
he had so many different situations you
know that there were I actually thought
he would go to Boston because I thought
that was a viable option for him because
they were young and you know they were
on the verge of doing great things and
people would have been okay with that
yeah yeah and you know it was like he
didn't have to go to Golden State for
them to win a championship you know so
it was you know whether you could say he
and I were in the same predicament or
not I did I didn't have that many
options but do you think you could see a
scenario where KD and it feels like he's
sensitive sensitive that he responds to
all this Twitter nonsense here that he's
ruined the NBA he you know they he's
heard that criticism that maybe he says
all right I'll win another title in
Golden State and then I'm gonna leave
Golden State after this year and could
you see him joining LeBron in Los
Angeles I mean I it's hard to say what
is as possible I don't think that he
should make a decision
so what people say about him you know
because he made this decision in the
first place because he wanted to do what
was best for him and he wanted to win so
and now he's in it you got to stick with
it you got to ride it out you know I
don't know why he doesn't just embrace
being a villain like okay that's not you
there's not gonna like me yeah that's it
scoreboard that's why I do say just
scoreboard no matter what people are
gonna disagree with whatever you do what
you got to know is this is your life is
what you get to do on a daily basis and
you you're the one if we're right in
this movie you're the star of it so star
do it but also I don't think he would
want to help LeBrons legacy because the
more titles LeBron wins the further away
he gets from Kevin Durant Kevin Durant's
gonna end up with probably more titles
than LeBron James not that he's a better
player than LeBron but he's probably
thinking of if I go to LA I could help
LeBron win one or two more titles but I
don't think when you're in it and yet
opportunity I don't think guys think
about legacy at that time because you
did from one year to the next and I
guaranteed to win a championship even if
you're you're stacking on a pretty good
team there's no guarantee because you're
always so worried about injuries going
into every every year you just never
know like you like your odds but you
just never know so what you have stayed
in Cleveland or would you have gone to
launch and given the rosters if you're
LeBron if I'm LeBron you know I would
think that what we put together and
clean.the we could put together anywhere
because if you the way they made the
trade in midseason they they traded I
think eight guys away and and so when
you think of a team like that LeBron is
certainly thinking we can make this work
in a bigger market and you know it
almost gives him leverage into his after
basketball career at the same time so
you know I don't I think that there was
a good move on would you rather work
with Lanza ball or Ben Simmons Ben
Simmons because Ben Simmons has great
height he's not a great shooter yet but
if you're gonna help their shooting
mm-hmm your shooting coach would you
rather have
Ben or Lanza yeah I'm taking been you
know lonzo's farm looks like it's kind
of baked in you know and I don't know
how much he can improve on that I think
he can't improve on it I don't know it's
it's it's like you hate to take a
professional athlete and and change
their shot completely so could you
change Lonzo shot that's hard to say
because I'm wondering and I pointed this
out on the air before that Cady starts
on the left side and then moves over if
I could get Lonzo to start a little
higher to go over I wonder if that would
help him again if that it's got to be up
to that guy that's willing to do that
but a lot of it is all about your body
positioning getting to your shot anyway
because you know look at Kevin Martin
you know Kevin Martin for his 12 14
years in the NBA he he had one of the
best three-point balls out there and he
was way over here like half the time we
didn't know if he was gonna shoot the
ball it was like I don't know when he's
loading up so you have to pretend that
you have to think that he's about to
load up even when he just kind of had
the ball and he kind of pushes it from
here but it's it's just efficiency and
everything else like if you have a
slower trigger then you had to have your
body and your feet ready earlier so you
know I don't know if I would change
Lanza ball shot if he's comfortable with
it what I would do is trying to work
with him on everything else get me free
throws right and that's 50% from the
line and that's that's all about you
know sitting down with this kid and
trying to figure out is he committed to
the work like committed to putting in
the preparation every single day so he
understands what he's dealing with
because to me free throws I used to be
that guy at home and I know there's a
lot of people like this that I've
watched guys I'll be in high school
college nothing look at these guys
they're making all this money and they
can't make it free throw and then when I
got to Navy I realized you know free
throws are so much more you know there's
more into it a lot of mental in there
yeah it's like when you go on the free
throw line and you're down two and you
got a tie the game you gotta make two
free throws like whether you're home on
the road each situation presents his own
its own circumstances so
you it goes back to routine like if you
don't have routine if you don't have a
consistency if you don't practice that
you know when you're at home or wha when
you're in practice there's so much that
will cause you to miss that shot you
know and it can snowball in the wrong
direction and the problem is is in 82
games if you're on a bad streak it can
continue for a long time you ever shoot
an air ball from the line I don't think
no I don't think so
hmm would you would you end up 90 over
90 percent from probably 89 90 somewhere
around yeah so one of the top 10
free-throw shooters of all time yeah
and that just work that's it that's it
he's not talented yeah you know I credit
a lot of people don't notice but I
credit a player in Milwaukee by the name
of Jeff Nord guard earlier in my career
i played with him and Jeff and I used to
always have a free throw game he was an
incredible free throw shooter and early
on he gave me somebody to challenge
somebody compete against and he was it
was always swishes always swishes and so
I constantly was out there doing it with
him and so for the rest of my career
that she went from 82% when you were
lucky or you know and then you went to
92% yeah cuz I was later and now was the
difference I didn't know what
challenging myself on the free-throw
line was all about I didn't understand
like it's a real thing to shoot
free-throws after every routine and a
really put you know shoot it's one thing
like you going to a practice and you're
down there by yourself you just shoot
ten free-throws walk off the floor it's
not real yeah it isn't because can you
draw back on this this these
circumstances when you're in a game
because then the game is so much more
intense help Shaq I'd like to think I
could but again I think the guys that
really get better the ones that really
want help you know it's always we always
say if you come to the situation with
your cup already fool I can't put
anything in it you know you can't just
think you know everything because you're
talking about like extremely incredible
athletes and some of the best of all
time and if you come with that mentality
that I don't need help or I'm good I
can't help you
hey some point LeBron every time I want
to the free-throw line or I was shooting
shots LeBron was like let me help let me
get some shots up with you and then he
would ask questions you know when you're
shooting free-throws why do you do it
like this and you know what do you see
in my free-throw and he always asked for
help and for a minute there he was
getting better at his free-throws and I
don't know what his percentages were
this past year but you got to be willing
to ask for assistance no matter how good
or bad you are way even the Great's adds
something because magic added the
outside shot Mike started going down on
the blocks and that's what I you get to
a certain level and then do you add to
your game when you get to a certain
level
it's like Vince became a 3-point shooter
Jason Kidd became a three-point if
you're if that willingness to add to
your game or evolve it separates the
goods from the greats to the Hall of
Famers there well well Vince was always
a three-point shooter he could shoot you
know young but he's just so athletic it
overshadowed this 3-point shooting and
even when he was dunking on people he a
lot of times people would always say
he's settled when he shot the threes
because they're like they just want to
see him get the ball and go down there
and dunk on somebody so yeah it's you
just you just I think it's it's the
evolution of the player and how the game
goes because we always say once the
league figures you out yeah you have to
have a go-to move a secondary move and
then you might have to have a third move
but if you stick to the same move like
you if you're playing in a playoff
scenario then you're gonna have a bad
playoffs because we we know
percentage-wise that you go to the right
90% of the time okay but harden goes
left all the time
Manu Ginobili went left all the time
mm-hmm we still couldn't stop him well
the thing about men who was they used to
clear that side for him too and he'd
start from all the weight he's like
almost a half-court and it's hard to
make a guy go right from there because
you're basically giving him a straight
line anyway James Harden when he goes
left if you take his left he steps back
in any shoots a three so and he's good
at doing that so that's his secondary
move off of taking that away from him or
when he takes three steps back to shoot
the three yeah three steps yeah or or
he'll he'll just step he'll Euro step
from the left to the right side but he
always finishes on his left so
it is it's is difficult to stop the
great players but what you have to do is
make them uncomfortable any update on he
got game to none not yet come on we got
the script here I think we're no we
don't got the script I have it in my
head bill yeah we have it in I had to
but we gotta get this thing down on wax
you can't just we can't it's gotta go
from our minds out into the paper you
know I think Spike Lee's got to throw
the kitchen sink can't you well spike
just finished black clansmen yeah which
I haven't watched it but I heard his
great reviews great mom and so he's been
pretty busy and that's what I tried to
stay in in the forefront of his mind so
every now and then we said we got to sit
down and start writing this thing down
I've had a lot of people reach out to me
and say add
I'll for the right to script I want to
write the script I want to get this
thing going
do you have denzel's cell number
I don't but we're always like one or two
people removed okay yeah and again he's
busy too like he's like putting out two
or three movies I know your nickname I
didn't know that that this was your
nickname and you said this at your Hall
of Fame speech do you want to let the
audience know what your nickname was
later in your career well I mean my
nickname was I had a couple different
nicknames but the one that ultimately
ended up defining me a lot was oh and
[Music]
you know the some people used to say
like how you grew up and like some kids
you say I thought my name was damnit
because my dad my name is and so every
time I turn around I'm on the floor I
would hear oh you know because I was in
a position where I wasn't supposed to be
in the minds of the opposing coach
because that guy guarding me his only
job was to stay on me and it was
frustrating because you're watching
defensive scheme where you I see my
point guard just dribbled right down the
lane I'm telling a guy like yo you
should help you know you should help
because I'm not going anywhere I'm part
of like I'm just standing over in the
corner
and then the gas thing is I know I'm not
supposed to leave you at all
and then the ball goes up he's standing
on me thinks he guards me neither turns
around he looks and then when he looks
back I'm gone and then the ball ends up
in my hand and then he's like a coach of
sandals everybody and then they take him
out of the game because you're not
supposed to leave them that's just human
nature because you know you know you
when do we ever play a game of
basketball where you look at one guy and
you're not supposed to leave him like
you help Yelp defense go get the rebound
whatever but you basically have to face
guard me so you know where I am at all
times and and I tell you one guy they
used to do that and they used to drive
me wild with Bruce Bowen right he knew
I'm not leaving you I'm not even gonna
go to the basket Tim's down there
I'm not even going I'm not gonna turn my
head and if you try to go to the basket
I'm gonna elbow you and knock you to the
ground which happened a couple of times
it's a great nickname and it's a it's
great to have you in studio we
appreciate it rain congratulations again
on the whole thing well deserve thank
you Dan and uh you know if you want me
to put on a clinic during the commercial
break I'll do that as well maybe well
maybe you just watch me shoot well you
know you said that I was the second best
shooter yes in this yeah he might do
this building but I think some of these
other guys in here now they can take you
down no they go no it's not true so you
might be like fourth or fifth because I
see some jump shots and you're great
that you know that they're raising their
hands too late and you don't drink do
you no no yeah by a you're sounding like
you yeah
don't tug on superman's cape ray don't
do that well that was Reggie Miller when
I play together yeah all right we'll
come back we'll get to your phone calls
as well this is the Dan Patrick show
did you challenge me like that anything
you bet $20 I couldn't make that I
didn't bit I was just about a
hypothetical I won I don't do a
hypothetical
well I deal real that's why that was
real now that's all that was it gives me
okay shooting
I'm saving I just go like that that's
all that was right that's like you
against the Spurs hit the jumper that's
it you off say thank you know what my
nickname was I Jordan hits the shot
against Utah goes in after the
championship and he gets up ready to
leave after I do the interview he goes I
said man it's a shame your retirement is
I had like a piece of you he goes what
the bleep what you say so he's got his
uniform champagne sweat and yell hold
him
stand up beside my suit tie on get R an
interview Phil Jackson how the bleep
would you garden I did one of these into
the middle of his back he said I would
then he's starting to person knowing
maybe I would do the forearm in the back
he'd go I would crush like he was
cursing I sit down and Phil Jackson goes
you see what I've had to deal with I'll
tell you the difference because if I
play like in a regular pickup game like
somehow who doesn't play professionals
you don't understand the force you play
with you know professionals because of
your guard me yeah it feels it's like
you go like this play through somebody
yeah cuz in the NBA defensively that
guy's breaking up and he's using this
strength so you don't ever see the
difference in the strength because both
forces are fighting on each other for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel two three
nine on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]